the following is an excerpt for my brand
new audiobook millions of little threads
the complete audiobook is available now
and you can find it through the link in
the description below at one hour long
it's an accessible but intense listen
and at just 3.99 it costs about the same
as a cup of coffee in it we explore near
future world where brain machine
interfaces have become the norm a brain
machine interface or BMI is a device
that interacts with the user's brain
signals allowing the user to control it
with their mind alone the story reflects
on themes like the nature of progress of
technology and of what it means to find
oneself caught in the whirlpool of
existence if you enjoy speculative
fiction or philosophical content
somewhere between Kafka and black mirror
or would like to hear me explore darker
and more complex themes which at times
might extend beyond the boundaries for
what is suitable for YouTube I think
you'll really enjoy this story
now on to the preview
Kennedy sat while an automated voice
called out names over the Lobby's
speaker system while he waited he used
an AR application that allowed him to
watch the real-time perspective of other
people who live stream their lives and
sold their decisions and actions to
Their audience
he watched one of his favorite streamers
named Pico who often did man on the
street stuff asking random people
questions and doing absurd things in
public spaces
Kennedy found him completely obnoxious
but there was something about watching
another person's Madness that made him
feel saner
he did this for several hours and still
had not yet been called
he could have sworn he had gotten there
before several of the other people who
had been called in
as Kennedy was beginning to think
something was wrong the automated voice
said now serving Kennedy Weatherly in
Rome number 103.
Kennedy quickly jumped up exhaling with
relief
two doors opened at the front of the
lobby next to where he scanned in
once inside Kennedy walked down a long
Corridor Sleek metal doors lined both
sides of the hall he read the room
numbers as he passed by them
it felt like the hall went on forever
when Kennedy finally approached a door
that read Number 103 it opened
automatically
he poked his head inside there was no
one just a surgical chair in the middle
of the room two white bionic arms that
look like prosthetic human arms and
several other pieces of sleek machinery
please confirm your identity by stating
your name and displaying your ID an
automated voice said Kennedy did as he
was instructed and the door closed
behind him
thank you you may take a seat Kennedy
The Voice continued
Kennedy sat in the surgical chair a red
light on the side of the chair turned
green one of the robotic arms moved
toward him and handed him a small metal
cup containing three pills
please swallow all three tablets these
are Conscious Sedation tablets they will
help you relax and block any pain during
the procedure
Kennedy took the cup and the robotic arm
retrieved a small bottle of water and
handed it to him please confirm once you
have taken the tablets
Kennedy swallowed them I have taken the
tablets Kennedy said the chair reclined
and raised up slightly
a minute passed and nothing happened
then Kennedy began to feel a soothing
surge of bliss swell up from his chest
and washed over his body the world
outside of him dissolved away along with
the sense of self
everything felt good
he felt an intimation of Hope for what
could be
he softly smiled and his eyes rolled
back
please keep your head straight and stay
as still as possible the voice said a
helmet-like half dome-shaped device
moved on to Kennedy's head it began
scanning his brain while simultaneously
drilling a small hole into his skull
once a small dime-sized hole had been
drilled the machine discarded the piece
of his skull and began implanting
hundreds of tiny threads each with
hundreds of independent electrode arrays
connecting hundreds of thousands of
electrodes to neurons throughout
Kennedy's brain it then implanted the
learner BMI device into the hole which
was connected to all the threads on the
other side finally it coated over and
sealed the device in with a skid like
super glue
please remain in your seat until further
instructions it should take around 30
minutes for the sedation tablets to wear
off
Kennedy felt a slight pain in his head
but it was mild and offset by his
growing excitement and anticipation
after 30 minutes passed the chair
returned to its upright position
congratulations you are now fully
integrated you can activate your BMI by
holding down the button on the top of
your device for three seconds before
exiting please be sure to take your
learn a BMI 6s package with you which
contains your instruction manual and
wireless charging port please note that
you must be within 20 feet of your port
to ensure reliable charging speed If you
experience any issues or complications
please visit learn a support for
additional assistance
a brief silence filled the room
thank you and have a wonderful day
Kennedy got up grabbed the small
circular box on a stand over by the door
and then left back down the hallway
he arrived back at his apartment once
inside he sat on his couch paused for a
moment and then held down the button on
top of his head
a heads-up display screen appeared in
front of him but it wasn't in front of
him
it was inside his head
[Music]
thank you so much for watching if you
would like to hear the rest of the story
The Complete audiobook is available now
you can find the link to it in the
description below once you purchase it
you will be able to download the
audiobook file directly which you can
listen to on any device anywhere even
while offline
I've been wanting to create a collection
of mid-length audiobooks for a while now
and if this one is well received it will
be the first of more to come so I would
love to hear what you think
through this medium I can explore darker
and more complex themes use language and
cover topics potentially inappropriate
for YouTube and develop longer more
fleshed out ideas all without any
limitations or restrictions concerns
about algorithms or constraints
associated with video or book format the
audiobook is one hour long and costs
only 3.99 and as a special thank you
anyone who downloads it in the first 48
hours will also receive a free ebook
file of my debut book notes from the end
of everything
as always regardless of whether you get
the audiobook thank you so much for your
continued support in any and all the
ways you do all regular content will
continue as usual and remain completely
free my goal is to continue to
thoughtfully build and expand the
content offering under the pursuit of
Wonder umbrella into all sorts of
mediums and your support and purchases
directly contribute to this growth
toward continuously bigger and more
ambitious projects in the future so
again thank you